I am Daniel Desjardins and I am a scout master with through 4.2.6 in
London Dairy, New Hampshire. This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored
by Backers Like Me. And now it's the old scout master.
Two penguins and a boy scout walk into a convenience store and they're carrying
a canoe And the clerk looks at him and says, hey, is this some kind of joke?
Yeah, see what I did there. Hey, this is podcast number 343..
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green. It's mailbag time.
That's right. We heard from James Rogers, who's the scout master of troop 58 in
Ashburn, Virginia, And he said: I love your website. Since I became the scout
master two years ago, I often find myself referring back to your site
for your wise words, James. if you do find any wise words on the site, let me know
so I can look at them, please. I appreciate your compliment. Thank you very much.
I'm always glad that things are at least marginally helpful. Frank Maynard got
in touch with us Now. Frank is the author of a blog called Bob White Blather
And you really ought to check it out. If it's not already on your reading list,
it should be. Frank wanted to comment on the question we answered about the
way that Scouters deal with district and council relationships, the way
units deal with it, And Frank had this to say: he said your first contact
should be with your unit commissioner, who is a key member of your volunteer
leadership team. They're there to help you have a successful unit,
give you support you need from the district and council. So get in touch
with your commissioner and articulate your concerns and those of the parents
in your unit. Hopefully they will be able to help you and a good idea is to
add them to your email list so that they're getting the same announcements
that everyone else in the troop is, and make sure to invite them to attend
your committee meetings. If you don't have a commissioner, you don't know who
they are. Contact your district executive and remember you can also help
out the district or council yourself. You don't have to take on a leadership
role. You can always help with a camp or a day camp or another kind of
district or council event, And I certainly agree with Frank's advice.
Thank you, Frank, for kind of rounding out the subject. on that Heard from
John Quintana. He says: my spouse and I just came home from an
Eagle Court of Honor for our oldest son and another Scout from our
troop And the Steve Miller band tuned, Fly Like an Eagle came to mind.
I'll give everybody a moment to think about that. You know the tune right.
The song's aspirations are like the charge given to Eagle Scouts: flying
into the future. because you know, time keeps slipping into the future,
It comes to mind that our Eagles don't fly so much as hike one foot in
front of the other, sometimes with blistered feet. Most would like
to sprout wings and fly during a hike. Yes, you're right, John.
I've been with Scouts that have seen the Northern Lights for the
first time, climbed mountains, braved cold weather. I've been
honored to help bring these experiences to them. Of the 55,186
young men who achieved Eagle Rank in 2016,, we don't really want
them flying into the future quite so quickly. We need them hiking
and inspiring the rest of us. There were two more Eagles who
opened their eyes today to go into the world toward uncharted
paths, and for that we should be thankful, And I couldn't agree
more with you, John. Thanks so much for those thoughts And
congratulations to you and your family for your son's achievement
One. one path ends and another begins. right Over on
Facebook last week got some comments about our last podcast,
number 342.. Jerry Fraley said the best recruitment is a good
outdoor program where the Scouts decide what to do. Couldn't
agree with you more, Jerry, And that's why I emphasize the
idea of inviting prospective Scouts to go camping. Get them
out camping, That's the heart of the program. Jim Brown said. I
am the official recruiter for our council here in Alberta, Canada.
I find little difficulty in recruiting youth. The major
difficulty lies in recruiting adults. Well, it's a different
kind of recruiting, I guess, and getting adults to
volunteer can sometimes be a bit of a bit of a challenge,
If it's helpful at all. Jim, one of the things that I've
hit on over the years is to ask people to help with tasks
rather than get them to take on roles. You know, a task has
a beginning, a middle and an end. It's something that's a
little more comprehensible to most people than actually
being in an open-ended commitment of occupying a volunteer
role. But once they have completed a couple of tasks
they'll probably express an interest in the role. part
of things Patrick Huber commented. I couldn't get
us the negative reply to the email about the district
and council. Well, Patrick, I wasn't trying to be
negative, I was trying to be reasonably neutrally
positive. How about that? I mean, we all know how all
of this is supposed to work ideally. We know how
scout troops are supposed to work ideally and
districts are supposed to work ideally and councils
are supposed to work ideally, But we encounter it
at all kinds of different levels. maybe being a
little neutral or realistic sounded negative, but
that wasn't my intention. Hey, we're still out there
having a live chat every Tuesday morning around
8 am Eastern time. Sign on over at
scoutmastercgcom and join us. Like Sean Montano,
who is a scout master from Troop 925 in Katie,
Texas. Allen, who's an assistant scout master
from Tulsa, Oklahoma, Adam Roth is a cub master
in Plainview, New York. and Sean Mitchell is
with Troop 27 in Snyder, Texas, where he's an
assistant scout master. All those folks signed
on to the chat for their first time this past
week, along with many others who we call our
frequent fliers, who show up almost every time we
have a chat. It's always good to check in with everybody.
Sometimes we discuss serious things and sometimes we just
don't. Once again, Tuesday mornings around
8 am Eastern time, you can lurk and just
see what's being chatted about, or you can join in
the conversation. I hope you do Watch our
Facebook feed and our Twitter feed for an
announcement when the live chat will be happening.
Well, I want to pause and thank everybody who
helps make the blog and the podcast possible.
There's two ways to do that. You could be a
backer or you can be a patron And joining
the ranks of backers this week, make a one-time
payment in support of the blog and the podcast
are Scott Madden, Alan Urlemans, Chris
Thornhill and Gary O'Neill, And then we added
a couple of patrons to this week, and patrons
sign up for a voluntary monthly subscription.
that helps us out. And I want to thank Linda
Bastion. Linda Bastion, if the name seems
familiar, yes, that's Wade's mom And my fellow
scouter. thank you so much, Linda And David
Werner Both became patrons since the last
podcast. If you want to become a backer
or a patron, go to any page at
scoutmastercgcom. You'll find links in the
menu in the top right of any page And I'll
have links in this episode's podcast
notes. Well, the remainder of the podcast
will be taken up with answering some
email questions. How about that for a change,
or no change at all? Well, I hope they
find. I hope the answers are useful to you.
So let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all time boy scout.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks. And here's an answer
to one of your emails.
Well, his first email, the sender asked to
remain anonymous And it begins like this:
I have a scout who earned life rank three
years ago. about six months after that
he completed the six month requirement in
a position of responsibility. He's completed
all of his required merit badges And then
he disappeared for three years. About a
month or two ago he started working on
his Eagle project. Now he isn't coming to
troop meetings or events, but he's working
on his project. I became the scout master
two years ago And in that time I
haven't had the opportunity to see him
as an active member of our unit. If
somebody was to ask me: is he an active
scout, I'd have to say no. So my question
is: what would you do in my situation?
This scouts going to approach me and ask
me to sign off that requirement in Eagle
that says that he's an active scout, And
I'm wondering if I should get him to
be active in the troop for a few months
before I sign off that requirement.
Well, you know, the situation you
describe is pretty easy to sort out
Actually. first, there's really no
reason to require the scout to redo
any requirements. They have no expiration
date other than his 18th birthday. If
the active requirement is signed off in
his book, the fact that he fulfilled
that requirement never expires. okay, If
it's not, then it's time to sit down
and have a discussion with the scout.
But it kind of follows: if the
scout hasn't already fulfilled the
role of responsibility requirement,
he must have been active in his troop
to do so. So there's really
not a whole lot of question. that is
fulfilled the requirement. So let's
look at that active requirement for a
moment. It says be active
in your troop for a period
of at least six months as
a life scout. It does
not say be active for
the past six months,
It says be active
in your life scout. So once that
requirement's fulfilled, it never
expires. If the scout
didn't participate actively in the
troop for three years, that doesn't
nullify the fact that he's already
completed that requirement. Now I
understand you didn't necessarily
witness any of this service or
activity, but there's a lot of
requirements that get fulfilled that
we don't witness. like most
Meribadge requirements, correct, You
should not and may not
to become active again if he's already
fulfilled the requirement. It's
really just black and white policy.
that's very clearly spelled out in
the Guide to Advancement. So it's
really not my opinion, right? I mean,
this isn't a matter of opinion or
style or differences like that. It's
basically this is just the way that it
is. So happily
this doesn't really need to be a concern
of yours, and soon you'll have a new
Eagle Scout. I heard from George
Stockburger, who's with Troop 99
in nearby Newtown, PA,
and George said this:
I'm the advancement chair for our troop
and I'd like to get your opinion on how to
interpret the completion of first class
requirements 1a
and 2a. Okay, well,
my opinion
is worthless,
George,
you know some well.
I guess sometimes it's minorly helpful,
but my answer will not
be opinion. and George goes on to say:
here's the first class requirements I'm asking
about. 1a says:
quote: since joining, participate
in 10 separate troop and
patrol activities, 6 of
which included overnight camping.
and 2a
in part says: quote:
help plan a menu for one of the above
campouts. So George
asks: is it appropriate to give
credit for completing the camping
requirements in 1a if the
Scout has not completed the cooking requirements
for 2a?
requirement 1a doesn't specifically state
that the cooking requirement in 2a must be
completed to receive credit for the camping
requirement. George, you answered your own
question because you're right.
requirement 1a doesn't specifically
state that the cooking requirement in
2a must be completed to receive credit
for the camping requirements. So these are
not interdependent. If
they were, it would be very
clearly stated. while this is a pretty
simple answer, I want to take the opportunity
to point something out that I say
very often. the
requirements are really pretty simple.
if you sit down and read them
without trying to interpret them.
if you run up against
something in a requirement that seems
to challenge the way that you
understand something, that is good
and then find out if the way you
understand things is correct or not,
I've had the opportunity to correct myself
in by just simply reading the
requirements and going: oh well, that's
not what I thought at all, that's.
oh okay, I see
the way that the requirement is written
is different from the way I understand
things. so instead
of looking for something
that is not there or trying to
bend the wording of the requirement to the
way I understand things,
I think I will just take it at face value.
it makes life so much simpler
and in my
ideal scouting world. of course
every requirement would be very easy to
understand and there would be no question about them.
but you know I don't get
to live in that world and neither do you,
fortunately. I'll just repeat
myself. read the requirements simply.
if what they say
at face value challenges one of your
assumptions, then challenge that assumption,
see if it's right or wrong. it's a good
thing to do. it makes you a better scouter.
and our third advancement
related email will remain
anonymous and it says this:
I'd like to get your thoughts on the
scoutmaster conference. my interpretation
is that it is objective,
but the ones being run by our
scoutmaster seem to be subjective.
I replied with this. I said
I have plenty of advice
on how to conduct scoutmaster conferences,
but their purpose
is very clearly explained
in the guide to advancement, which says
in part- quote: it is
a forum for discussing topics such as
ambitions and life purpose
and goals for future achievement,
for counseling and also for
obtaining feedback on the unit's
program. unquote,
and you can find that in. ready.
here we are. it's guide to advancement,
section number time. do you
have your pencil ready? I'll give you a second.
it's section
four, point two, point
three, point five. I'll have a link
to this in the podcast notes, don't worry,
and that section is entitled the unit
leader or scoutmaster
conference. that's where I got the quote
that I just read to you. so this
isn't a matter of opinion or difference
in style. again, it's just
basically sitting right there in black and
white. it's easy and
you know, going along with my little sub
theme here, if that challenges
your assumption about what a scoutmaster's
conference is, you need to change your
assumption, because it's very
easy to understand. it's right there in black
and white. and the author of that email
got back to me with this
said: our scoutmaster conferences
seem to be well beyond what's described
on your site, as well as what I
can find in the scouting literature.
they generally run from one
one and a half hours after
a seventy five minute conference. my son
reported back that he did
not get signed off and the scoutmaster
wants him to come back and demonstrate a laundry
list of skills. the scoutmaster,
in an email to my
son, asserts that this
is not a test, but a scout
at your level should know about
the following skills in order for us
to have a conversation
to see where you are in scouting.
from my perspective, this
conference seems to have been a
test because he did not
pass all of the test areas
and thus was not signed off.
to be clear, he's met all the requirements
per the scout handbook
and has all of these things already signed
off. my reply to
that is: I'm sorry
that this scoutmaster doesn't get it-
and this is actually more common
than you'd hope. and this scoutmaster
can assert that what he's doing in a
conference is not a test, and I'll
bet he's already read the guide to
advancements that you can't retest.
so he said: well, I just won't call it
a test. well, I'm sorry,
you can call a dog an antelope,
but it's still a dog. and
what is happening is
that this scoutmaster has wrongly
assumed that he's supposed
to retest a scout on every skill
before he signs off
on a conference. so when you
read that section of the guide to
advancement it very clearly states:
the conference is not a test or a
pass, fail kind of an operation.
it's talking to a scout
about a given set of subjects,
checking up on the unit program,
seeing what kind of
experience the scout is having,
asking him what his goals are,
what his ambitions are. it's great.
it's a great talk to have
in the guide to advancement the recommended time
for a scoutmaster conference
from scout to life
is maybe 10 or 15 minutes
and it does allow that
an eagle scoutmaster
conference may go up to 30 minutes,
maybe longer. so if a
scoutmaster's conference is a long,
laborious test, taking an hour
to an hour and a half, somebody is not
understanding something properly. my best
advice usually in this situation
is to find another troop with a
scoutmaster who gets it, because
in my experience most of the time
trying to get somebody to change their mind about this
is a long, difficult and unpleasant process.
but the writer got back to me and said:
well, this is a new scoutmaster's heart's in the right place.
we'll work with him.
I don't want to really change troops
and you know more power to you.
I hope that works for you and I'm not saying that it won't.
all I'm saying is in my experience
it can be kind of difficult.
so I'm not going to go into
a great deal of detail about scoutmaster
conferences but I will have
in the podcast notes links
to a couple of posts I've written about it in the past.
scoutmaster conference is not particularly
difficult to understand.
there are no magic robes or top hats
or brass bands. it's just sitting down
and talking to a scout, and once
you've been around the block a few times and you've
done some scoutmaster conferences, you'll understand
what I mean. it's a great source
of information for you
and your fellow scouts about
how effective your program is,
and it's also a great way to get to
know a little bit more about your scouts.
so I hope all that helps.
I would love to hear from you if you have
a question or a comment. I'm going to tell you
how to get in touch with me in just a moment.
music.
well, thanks for listening to this
343rd edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
keeping in touch is oh so
simple. yes, it is.
if you're a social media person,
we're all over social media.
we've got 16,000
plus people on
facebook.
we've got a course of tweeters on twitter.
we even do the Pinterest thing
and we pin Pultritunes pictures
and proffer them publicly with a parcel
of prolific pinners on Pinterest.
you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube.
you can go directly to scoutmastercgcom
and sign up to receive
email updates to the blog
in the podcast.
you can read about 1600 different articles
there and you'll have
access to all the past editions of the
podcast. but if
the whole social media
thing just is a big turn off for you
if you can't face facebook
and twitter makes you head. listen, I understand
old timer. so here's what you can do
is you can zoom into the
late 1990s and
fire off an email. email. you say,
what's that? well, find an 11.
they'll explain it to you.
but you can get in touch with me at
Clark at scoutmastercgcom,
and that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
now, if none of those
ways of getting in touch work for you,
find a hollow log in the woods,
get a couple of sticks
and use morse code.
I have listening posts and agents everywhere
and we'll be sure to get back to you
with an answer to your question.
well, by now it should be abundantly clear
that the scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of anyone in particular other than myself.
that's right. this is just
my way of lending a hand
to my fellow scouts and having a bit of fun.
and speaking of fun, here he is
our founder, Sir Robert
Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping,
why? thank you, sir?
until next time, everyone.
you.